Hey look at you guys you look so fresh
and so new guess who doesn't look so
fresh and new it's me and I'm totally
fine I can completely accept that fact
that right now I am feeling I'm feeling
rough I you know just it's just not
feeling my best um
so I'm off to Sundance I woke up at 4
o'clock this morning and I just opened
up my phone it was like why am i way cuz
I know I have to get on a plane I
thought I would update some of my apps
and as I me entered my way into the App
Store I noticed that there was this game
called shades not sponsored downloaded
it I wanted to wake up at 5 a.m. so that
I can pack for my flight and instead I
started playing this stupid game I
stupid I mean it's really freaking fun
didn't fall back asleep also didn't pack
so here I am seconds before I many
seconds after I should have probably
already left I'm vlogging that's what
I'm doing it's what I'm doing thinking
about the game I impact my house is a
disaster
my life is partially in shambles that's
the way things that's the way things
happen so I'm off to the airport Jenna
will be there
Butare will be there and I'm gonna take
you guys on a fun little trip to Utah
I'm cold I'm cold already actually I'm
sweating right now that that's yeah
anyway let's go back to this camera holy
moly
holy moly let's hope that you're a good
camera let's hope that you're the bus
that you could be see you guys the
airport really you're really good okay
how we stopped you you said you found a
while I just seen I would like to show
you
this this does not look like healthy not
a healthy meal
I'm not well I'm not well what's wrong
should I do in him should I come in make
a list right make a list you douche do
you want them to be the less you need we
only need the synopsis do some deductive
reasoning
serious berry is a wild foot tall has
been spotted over there
I picked myself up away we're gonna head
out to get dinner we're gonna go to I
don't what we're gonna do actually I
have no idea
but this is all our humble abode so nice
Betar just suck toes but oh it's okay
now just a little Aaliyah almost like a
little bit of a buck so this is our
hungry dining room we've got a bathroom
this place is super cute this is awesome
eat sleep and ski we will be eating and
sleeping over you know ski we have to
get some eggs so we can make breakfast
this is great look at this what is this
so perfect it's coffee
it is coffee you better get me a present
I would definitely want the coffee I'm
like as a new camera so far what do you
guys think are you liking it are you
enjoying it do you think what do you
think Tuesday I had a yeah well I had an
accident you know the my shampoo leaked
and my makeup bag and also a a black
eyeshadow Brooke really really really
not a Tuesday
it's so cold world not sure bunk up oh
so I didn't film anything tonight we
didn't really do much we kind of much to
dinner and I was so hungry that I just
didn't think about filming we would
until like a little party and now I'm
editing some stuff but tomorrow is gonna
be really fun so I'm covering the
Billboard Music event so they're doing a
bunch of interviews and concerts and all
kinds of fun stuff and tomorrow I have
an amazing list of people that I get to
interview and first on the list is Kevin
Bacon so I mean I'm stuttering I'm so
excited
tomorrow I will I promise I won't I
won't
I don't I might I love Kevin Bacon I'm
such a big Kevin Bacon fan so this is
gonna be really excited are you gonna
ask him about the pig that same Kevin
Bacon there's probably like 50 million
pigs named Kevin Bacon but I'm really
really pumped up about it and really I
love the following good show that's
actually the only reason that I started
watching the following that and um the
one guy that does cuz he used to direct
on Vampire Diaries so psycho like you
and I love Kevin so this is great so
that's really all I've got for you I
don't know what happened in this vlog
you can go check out the blog on Jen's
channel it's me Jenny girl see you guys
later hopefully I get to post some of
the interviews here my channel - I don't
even know what I'm saying I'm so excited
get bacon